Let's Go Big
Alexander Reardon
ALEXANDER: Hello, yes.
Yes, as mentioned I am going to be talking
to you all about big numbers, so these are
numbers that are bigger than what we can naturally
do in JavaScript by default.
That's my Twitter handle there if you want
to find me.
I was pretty late to the party in terms of
Twitter so the last letter of my first name
and last name are collapsed but you can find
me there.
Just a bit of a warning.
There will be some math in this talk.
It's kind of hard to talk about big numbers
without talking about math but I will try
to keep it as easy and light as I can.
So firstly, numbers.
What are their characteristics?
What are the defining features about numbers?
So firstly we want to be able to store some
value that then we want to retrieve at some
later point, potentially print it out on an
user interface, but really the unique and
defining characteristic of numbers is the
ability to do operations on those numbers,
these pre-defined mathematical things, so
things like addition, subtraction, multiplication
and division.
Now, JavaScript only has one number type and's
a 64 bit, and this isn't unique to JavaScript,
you will find it in other languages like Ruby
and Python.
So let's look deeper.
64 bits, this is the first bit we use to control
the signs, positive or negative.
The next 11 bits, I like to think of them
as the scale, so this is how big or small
the number is and then the last 52 bits control
the actual value of the number.
Now, I've got 52 bits written there because
it sort of has 53 bits in that it assumes
53 but the first bit is always 1 so we can
store 53 bits of information there but we
only have 52 bits and this number system is
very similar to scientific notation.
So you have a value, in this case 8.12, and
times by some scale to give us our result,
and this is exactly how floating point numbers
work as well.
Now, I mentioned we have 53 bits and it's
no coincidence that the maximum value we can
store inside these numbers, this is what happens
when we set all of those in the value components
to 1, we get 2 to the 53 minus 1.
That's our maximum value that we could store
and if you have seen that number around but
you didn't know where it came from, it's number
dot max safe integer, is what it is.
We get this huge number here known as number
dot max value but it's kind of a bit useless
for what we want to do in that if you have
a number, say in this case this, and you add
one, you get what you expect but if you add
one again you get something you didn't expect,
it doesn't do anything and you get all this
weirdness.
For our purposes we are going to say because
the defining characteristic of numbers was
these operations we really don't want to be
going above that number or we will have unexpected
consequences so that's where JavaScript is.
Now, let's think about how we could go bigger,
how we could push numbers to both store numbers
much bigger than max safe integer and do operations
on them.
You might ask why would I be interested or
care about big numbers?
There are valid and practical uses for big
numbers, say if you are dealing with big distances,
say astronomical units, or you are doing any
accumulation of big historical data so say
counting the number of characters in tweets
over a period of years you might start to
run into these problems as you keep piling
counts on counts.
Another common use case is if you are shifting
decimals, so say you have a decimal value
you want to shift to become an integer value,
you might hit these problems.
But really it's a bit of fun.
It's to see how far we could push this idea,
overcome this limitation of 64 bit floating
numbers and it's also a bit of a challenge
for us as well and hopefully we will learn
a lot by trying to overcome these barriers.
There's a lot of different ways of doing big
numbers.
I will link this on Twitter afterwards, but
it has a few other ways of doing them, and
hopefully after this talk you will see that
there are probably lots of different ways
that I didn't even explore about doing big
numbers so let's get into it.
This is my first technique and probably the
most basic but very interesting, and that's
converting numbers into strings, so say we
have the number 125, we simply convert it
to the string 125.
This is really easy, we take a number and
convert it to the string, this is the format
of that system and by doing this simple trick
how big can we go?
So say we have three slots the biggest number
we can store in three slots is 999 and in
a more general sense if we had n slots we
could store 10 to the n minus 1.
Which raises a question: how long is a string?
How big can these things be?
The answer today is pretty vague.
It's not locked down in any spec anywhere.
But if you test in browsers and Node you will
find this is a safe power to use, to the power
of 27.
That's safe and consistent so that's what
we will use today.
it will be this but today we will be using
to the power of 27.
So what does that even mean, how big have
we gone?
I've come up with this analogy which I will
use for the rest of the talk as well.
So say we had a sheet of paper and on that
sheet of paper we start writing numbers so
on the first line we write 1, then 1,000 on
the next line, a million on the line after
that, a billion, and so on.
And each line is a centimetre big.
The thing to note is that each centimetre
is a thousand times bigger in value than the
centimetre before it.
So with JavaScript numbers we can get 6cm
down this page until we hit that max safe
integer.
If we use this string method it would take
474km worth of paper to store this number
which is staggering when you consider that
each centimetre is a thousand times bigger
in value than the centimetre before it so
this is a really simple technique and we've
completely blown away that max value that
we had before.
So it's from here to Berlin and back twice,
with each centimetre being bigger than the
one before it.
This is a table I am going to keep referring
to as we go to record our progress, so simply
switching to decimal strings we have a huge
increase in scale.
You might think that's great but really what
we care about with numbers is the ability
to do operations.
I think the screen has gone.
Here we go, so say we wanted to do addition,
with two strings, so we have a string, 256
and 182, how do we even begin to start doing
addition with these numbers?
Well, we could look at the first column on
the right.
We want to add 6 and 2 and we could create
some system where the character 6 plus the
character 2 yields the character 8 and not
do any math but because these are small integer
values we could lean on JavaScript numbers
under the hood to do these small, safe operations
so we will do that for convenience.
So we have 6 and 2 and get 8.
Move to the left and we have 5 plus 8 which
gives us 13.
We have a problem because we can't store 13
in one column so we do primary school mathematics
where we can subtract 10, carry 1 and [audio
problem] ... and carry that number to the
next column, we have one, plus, two, plus
one, which gives us 4.
We are able to add these strings which is
pretty fun.
What's interesting is that was a really nice
algorithm, looking at two numbers at the time
and constantly shifting down the number.
Let's take a look at subtraction.
This one is a little bit harder so say we
have 4,005 and want to subtract 11 from it.
So 5 minus 1 gives us 4, then zero minus 1,
we can't really do that so we start with a
lookup phase so we start looking down the
number until we find something that we can
borrow something from.
So we found 4, we take one from that, we can
carry a 10 back.
Now we can take something interest that so
that becomes a 9 and we can carry 1 over and
now we can do something, we can take 1 from
10 which gives us 9.
Then shifting down again we have 9 minus 0
which gives us 9 and 3 minus 0 which gives
us 3.
Okay, we've got our answer.
But that was kind of gross, right?
We had to start shifting down, then did this
search, then come back, and then search again
and if these were really big numbers this
could be extremely inefficient.
You might be searching back and forth, back
and forth a lot.
So this is much different to what we had with
addition where we were simply moving down
two digits at a time.
So that's just something to keep in your mind
that that's a pain point for this system.
Now let's look at multiplication.
Bear with me.
There is not too much heavy math more to go.
So multiplication: we could write a multiplication
algorithm but really once you have addition
you can deduce multiplication for free.
So you had 0, we add 10, we add 10, we are
done, you have an answer.
We could just leverage that addition function
we already had.
Admittedly it's not super-performant but you
have the idea.
Addition.
Same idea except now we are going to keep
subtracting from this number until we can't
subtract anymore.
We start with number 6, subtract 2, subtract
2, subtract 2, we can't subtract anymore,
but we can count the number of times we subtract
and so the answer is 3.
By having addition and subtraction we were
able to get division and multiplication for
free which is great.
So as soon as we create a system with addition
and subtraction we can create one that has
division and multiplication as well.
So we did pretty well.
We created a system which has a huge number
value as well as being able to do this pre-confined
mathematical operation, and we built this
system - again I will tweet this link at the
end - if you are interested you can have an
play with it and it works for decimals and
negative values too, so have a play with that.
Note I've said do not use in production, I
haven't tested it or anything, but have a
look at that.
So the next technique is binary strings, so
this is the binary representation, a 8-bit
representation of the number.
The max value is ... and why it's minus 1
is because I'm storing the binary in a format
called two's complement and I will explain
why that's important in a sec.
So now we have a bigger value than we started
with, with numbers but a smaller value than
our base 10 system.
That's because we are in base 2 and can't
store as much information but it's still 1,347
kilometres on this sheet of paper with every
centimetre being a thousand times bigger so
still a very big number but let's take a look
at subtraction in this system.
So we have the number 5 and minus 3 in binary
and we know this is going to give us 2 and
we can use this method called the two's complement
to model this in a different way so first
of all what we do is we flip the bits and
we add one, and then we can see if we can
just add like we would before, so in binary
addition one plus one, you carry the one and
you leave a zero, so we go over, now we have
1 in this column, this carry situation again,
1 plus 1, so zero and carry the 1.
Now we have 1 plus 1 again, we put 0 but we
are carrying a 1 into this area we don't care
about called the overflow bit and you just
throw it away.
What's interesting is we've ended up with
the number 2 so even though we had this subtraction
problem we were able to model it using addition.
So we started with subtraction, we flipped
the bits - oh, you can see the animation but
I can't.
So we actually ended up looking at it like
this.
We have been able to model subtraction as
if we are doing addition which is a really
nice way of looking at the problem.
Let's go bigger.
Where can we go from binary strings?
We can look at hexidecimal strings.
Hex is just a mapping 0 through 9 and 0 through
9 and A through F is 10 through 16 so we can
store values in each slot of a string so now
we have this new max value of 16 to the n
minus 1 which is bigger than we had in decimal
but it will have a bad subtraction story,
but we are now moving in the direction of
trying to chase bigger and bigger numbers
so this one is now 5037km on paper.
This leads to
the question: what could we store in the slot
of a string, what's the maximum thing?
This leads to my final technique, 16 bit strings
and to understand this we need to understand
how strings work a little bit better.
To understand strings we need to understand
Unicode so Unicode is really simple, just
a map of symbols to integers or symbols to
code points.
Code points, they just decided arbitrarily
that these symbols map to these integers,
that's all it is, and there's about 1.1 million
of them.
JavaScript is a language that has decided
that it's going to treat every 16 bit unit
of a string as one character, and I am going
to show you what that means.
Let's start with this string, the letter E.
It equates to the Unicode integer of 101.
You can pull that out from the string and
it's going to give you that integer back but
you will see in hexidecimal, it has a length
of 1.
This will be true for any character that has
a Unicode code point between 0 and 2 to the
power of 16.
Things get interesting when we start to move
to characters that are bigger than to the
power of 16 in integer value.
So in this case we have an emoji which equates
to a code point and you will see that it actually
equals in JavaScript two different Unicode
strings.
It has a length of 2 so even though visually
to us it seems like it's one character according
to JavaScript as a language that we deal with
it's two.
This gets even more crazy when you start to
introduce things like modifiers where, according
to Unicode, it's two huge numbers but JavaScript
needed four 16 bit strings to represent that.
So it looks to us like one character, JavaScript
is calling it four.
So really the biggest things that we could
store inside one slot of a string is anything
from 2, 0, to 2 to the power of 16.
So we have 2 to the power of 16 things we
could store in each of these slots.
To put it into perspective it if we look at
the piece of paper, with each centimetre being
a thousand times bigger than the one before
it, it would be from here to Sydney and a
little bit back again, how much paper we would
need to record that value.
But what about operations?
You know, if we had a string hash plus dollar,
what does that give us?
We saw this method before where we could pull
out the integer value so we could simply pull
that integer value out, do the addition and
if we really wanted we could save that result
back into a Unicode string so if you didn't
know hash plus dollar equals G. Cool.
So we've got a pretty big increase in scale
and it has pushed us to the limit of what
we could do with strings so where do we go
from here?
Let's have a look at arrays.
So firstly we had a string and I have been
very deliberate with my language in saying
that a string has slots.
Now, we can also think of an array of characters,
so we can think of a string as an array of
characters but we also have arrays in JavaScript
so technically we could store anything we
want in one of these slots, we don't have
to store just one character and the conclusion
of that is we could store one of these superstrings
that we've created in each slot of an array.
So how long is an array?
Well, an array is 2 to the 32 minus 1.
Just so you know.
Which means our new max value is this huge
thing here.
To put into perspective how much paper we
would need to store that number, you would
have to go from the sun to Pluto - I like
mentioning Pluto because it was a planet when
I was young and I like keeping it relevant
- so from sun to Pluto 135 times.
That's how much paper you would need.
Yes, it's about 3 trillion kilometres worth
of paper with each centimetre being a thousand
times bigger than the centimetre before it.
These numbers, I can't even process them.
This is just one level of deeper arrays.
There's nothing stopping us having arrays
of arrays, or arrays of arrays of arrays.
The numbers start to get absurd and I couldn't
think of any good analogies for them anymore.
Now, I have been thinking of mirroring, right,
can we actually store these things?
So let's have a look.
We know we have 16 bits per slot, there might
be some optimisation under the hood but let's
assume 16 bits per slot, 227 slots, so the
amount of bits is about 2 billion bits or
268 megabytes to store one of these strings
and if we are trying to store an array we
have 268 megabytes per slot, 232 slots, about
1 million terabytes to store these things
so definitely something you don't want to
be doing, so we are going to stick with this.
268 megabytes is something we can probably
deal with.
Now, what we could do is if we were running
in Node by default you get about 1.7 on a
machine, you could increase your memory, but
for starters we are probably going down an
approach we shouldn't be going down so let's
take a step back and think about what we've
learned from looking at this string approach
to doing math.
Firstly, we learnt that we can do almost any
operation if we can add.
If we are using a binary system, if we can
add, we can kind of do lots of different operations.
And we can add two numbers - we can add numbers
together, potentially really big numbers.
We only need to look at two digits of that
number at a time so just kind of looking down
the column, shifting to the right.
Shifting to the left sorry.
Okay, so let's take those learnings and apply
them somewhere else so say we have this file
and it's encoded in UTFA which means you have
flexible 8 bit encoding.
We have a binary string that's huge, much
bigger than we could store in memory at once,
and let's say we have two of those files.
We could open a stream to those files, this
is sort of like a live connection to the file
without reading anything in, and then we created
a buffer where we are just going to read in
one byte at a time from each of these files,
and this is why it was important that it was
UTFA because 0 and 1 fall in the first eight
bits, we will be able to read in one digit
at a time which is what we want to do, read
in one digit at a time from these files.
So we read in one digit at a time, we do the
operation, might save the overflow if there
is one in memory for a bit and then output
that one byte at a time to an output file,
and this is pretty cool.
So this means we could actually add incredibly
big numbers that we could never really store
in memory, by just kind of just looking at
two little things at a time and just adding
them and kind of passing it on.
I built this as well, it's there if you want
to check it out.
We have two input streams, say 1 and 0, you
add them, save and then add to the file.
It's very similar to what we had before where
we just keep shifting down.
We can do this on numbers that are much bigger
than we can store in memory, so now this table
starts to break down, right?
Our limiting factor is not - I'm sorry, I
know you probably can't see the bottom of
the screen right now but I've just written
"infinite" and your limiting factor is the
number you have on your machine which is a
pretty big increase in scale.
I didn't even bother to figure out how big
in terms of kilometres that would be.
But we can take this further.
What if we weren't even limited by our own
machine but instead distributed this number
across one machine so no one machine could
see the whole number at once but all these
no ones had pieces of the number, we could
store them using that and also create some
sort of protocol to do distributed operations.
Because we don't actually need to see the
whole piece of the number at once to see an
operation, you only need to see two digits
you could distribute and then screen that
output to someone who cares about it, so now
the limiting factor isn't our machine, it's
how many machines we have access to.
All right.
So we went big, we went really big, probably
bigger than you thought we were going to go
today, the limiting factor being the amount
of machines that you have.
We actually learnt a lot from implementing
a numbering system using strings which you
might have thought was a bit strange to start
with and we were able to take those learnings,
some of the nicer patterns we found about
dealing with strings and we were able to apply
that in a completely different way to build
on the system that maybe we didn't think about
when we first started.
So my big take away from today is: don't be
afraid to try something a little bit different.
You might actually get some learnings from
that that you can apply to some other problem,
or to find some solution that you didn't even
think about when you first started.
Yes, so you never know what you will learn
and where it will lead you.
Before I finish, I just want to acknowledge
a good mate of mine, Stephen Campaign, a math
mate of mine really helped me out so a big
shout out to him and also my amazing colleagues
whose ear I have been chewing off over the
last few months wrapping my head around these
problems.
If you do want to use big numbers in production
there is a library, you can use that.
Also if you are interested they are looking
at putting infinite precision integers into
JavaScript, there's a draft stage, proposal
hub you can check that out.
Great.
Thanks, everyone.
[Applause]
>> Wasn't that fantastic?
That was absolutely incredible, and that gave
me as somebody with, like, the fear of the
numbers the warm fuzzies, so I was pretty
happy about that.